STEPHANIE WONG:
Today we're talking
about Gartner results, Cloud
Logging, Unattended Projects,
and Private Service Connect.
I'm Stephanie Wong, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud," where
we serve you the
lowest latency news.
For the fourth
consecutive year, Gartner
has positioned Google as a
leader in the 2021 Gartner
Magic Quadrant for Cloud
Infrastructure and Platform
Services.
Our enterprise-ready
cloud provides you
the uptime,
performance, and scale
to run even your most
demanding workloads.
And not to mention,
it saves you money
and has unmatched security.
So check out the blog for more.
To help you offload
operational tasks associated
with running your own logging
stack, we offer Cloud Logging.
If you don't need to worry
about data residency,
Cloud Logging will
pick a region for you.
But if you do have data
governance or compliance
requirements, we're excited to
share that Cloud Logging now
offers more flexibility and
control by providing you
a choice of 23 regions to store
and process your logging data.
Things get busy, and it's not
uncommon to forget about one
of the many things
you've got going on,
including full projects.
To help you prune your
idle Cloud resources,
we're excited to introduce
Unattended Project Recommender.
It's a new ML-driven feature of
Active Assist that provides you
with a one-stop shop for
discovering, reclaiming,
and shutting down
unattended projects.
Check it out in the
Recommender API today.
Private Service
Correct is now in GA
and allows you to consume
services quickly, privately,
and securely.
With Private
Service Connect, you
can create private
and secure connections
from your Cloud
networks to services
like Cloud Storage or Big
Table and third-party services
like Elastic,
MongoDB, or Snowflake.
It creates service
endpoints in your VPCs
that provide private
connectivity and policy
enforcement, allowing
you to easily connect
services across different
networks and organizations.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.